you and I know the criticism comes with  public life but I felt it was important  that I defend the faith of tens of  millions of Americans against I think  against that kind of slander and and I  did so and you know I give joy behar a  lot of credit she picked up the phone  she called me she was very sincere and  she apologized him one of the things my  faith teaches me is grace forgive as  you've been for so so does mine but I'm  not as good at it as you but but I said  but I said to joy of course I forgive  you that's it's part of part of my faith  experience but I did encourage her and  I'm still encouraging her to use the  form of that program or some other  public forum to apologize to tens of  millions of Americans who were who were  equally offended